[Music]  I want to tell you a story it's a story  you may think you know but you don't  over there  there's that  Papa  it speaks he's just a puppet no I'm not  I'm a real boy  people are sometimes afraid of things  they don't know  understand  ah we have found him our star  everyone shall love you and call your  name  I have something I'd like to give you it  is a school book which belonged to a  very special Boy The Boy you lost  [Music]  [Applause]  enough of this nonsense  hey where are you going  you tell him I love him  and I won't be a burden anymore  [Music]  [Music]  borrowed Soul while you may have eternal  life your loved ones they do not you  never know how long you have with  someone until they're gone  the boy loves you for who you are  guide him to be good  don't hurt him anymore you may have no  strings but I can't control you  bring him back to me  Pinocchio  life is such a wonderful gift